I very stupidly came up with the idea to
spend an entire day in Times Square it's
place that New Yorkers [ __ ] about
constantly it's not a place you want to
go to even waste ten minutes and then
instead I tried to waste 14 and a half
hours there are even asked to fight by
people walking their shitty mixtapes and
yeah I'm pretty miserable first thing I
did is I bought an I Love New York
t-shirt because it was the exact
opposite as I felt at that period of
time the headers are already coming off
like it's like so shittily made walked
around I sat down my people watched two
scariest words the New York language
show there's just not much to see you
see the lights you see the billboards
you see the million advertisements
literally I don't know there's nothing
that that's it's just it's a very shiny
thing and people want to look at the
shiny thing everyone is like hoarded
together you're like cattle just being
pushed from one street to the other
people bumping into you no one knowing
what side of the sidewalk to stay on
trying to think that this might actually
be what hell is like it's miserable he's
no room to breathe it's a hundred
percent more crowded here
so many better things to do in New York
even on a Wednesday well up Times Square
you officially won it's over
no I'm not happy I did this it was it's
dumb it was a very dumb idea